So, da bin ich, weil irgendwie passt mir mein Headset nicht mehr.
Ich vermute, mein Kopf ist größer geworden, am Headset kann das nicht liegen.
Seit gestern, zu hoher EQ durch die ganzen Prime-Subs.
Logic, danke für den Sub.
Pokers Overlay umstellen.
Chat, wie sieht es bei euch aus?
Aus wem wurden schon die Dislikes auf YouTube deaktiviert?
Also bei mir sind die Dislikes noch da.
Aber bei mir auf dem zweiten Rechner sind die Dislikes schon weg.
Weiß nicht, wie es bei euch aussieht.
Was sind es alle da?
Was steht heute an?
Das, was im Titel steht, nix.
Wir schwätzen ein bisschen, ich gucke mir ein paar Sachen an, wir gucken vielleicht
ein paar Videos.
Wir gucken uns vielleicht GitHub Trends an und ich kaufe mir eine SSD, weil ich festgestellt
habe.
Ich brauche noch eine Aufnahme-SSD, meine SSD ist fast voll.
Und ich habe keinen Bock, laufen die Sachen aufs Nass zu schieben, das dauert immer und
ich will ja weiter aufnehmen, Capture.
Ich bräuchte mal so irgendwie, sagen wir mal 1-2TB am besten per USB, USB-C, gucken
ob es da bei Amazon irgendwas gibt.
Von Kingfast, klingt nach irgendeinem AliExpress-Ding, sagte mal, was hatte ich mir noch mal bei
AliExpress, nein nicht Alice Weidel, was hatte ich mir noch mal bei AliExpress bestellt
das letzte Mal?
Das ist nämlich immer noch nicht da.
Was habe ich da für ein Müll drin liegen?
Ne, ne, ne, das ist es nicht.
Zack, ich muss mal kurz die VM starten.
Oder die VM, wie die coolen Leute das sagen.
Wir wissen ja, cool ausgesprochen ist alles, das ist viel geiler.
Es ist ja auch Jubantu anstatt Ubuntu und Java, ganz wichtig, Java, Java und Gyra und
Shit.
Und Jif, genau.
Ja, ich gucke erstmal bei Amazon, es ist nicht gerade irgendwie Black Friday Stels oder sowas
angesagt.
Ach ne, Early Black Friday Dienst, alter dieser Black Friday Kram, ne?
Das geht mir so unglaublich auf den Sack.
Erstens ist das zum größten Teil, außer die Amazon eigenen Sachen, mega Chebat, wenn
du bei Geist Stels guckst, bist du wirklich besser dran und, und das Schlimme ist, dass
ja mittlerweile, es ist ja nicht nur einfach Black Friday und Cyber Monday oder sowas in
der Richtung, es ist Early Black Friday, Black Friday, After Black Friday, Cyber Monday, Black
Friday Week, Black Friday Month, was kommt denn als nächstes, Black Friday Quartal oder
Black Friday Jahr, Black Friday Millennium, bald ist Dauer Black Friday, die, die übertreiben
es total, ich gucke mal ob es irgendwelche SSDs gibt, so, erstmal kurz, mal schnell gucken,
Storage kann man auch suchen, ach ne man kann ja hier oben, SSD suchen und dann Black Friday
auswählen, hier, davon hab ich doch jetzt auch schon eine, die sind nicht schlecht,
das einzige Problem was ich mit denen hab, ist, ich hab den einen, die überhitzen manchmal,
weiß ich ob ihr die auch schon mal, ob irgendjemand von euch den Kram hat, ich hab das Gefühl
die überhitzen manchmal, ja das hier ist Chebat im Leben kostet die normalerweise
keine 200 Euro, wir gucken jetzt einfach mal, Portable SSD Geist Stels, aber lasst uns weiter
gucken, nicht von Amazon, hier Chebaton, ja in rot, wobei mir das eigentlich vollkommen
egal ist, ob die in rot ist oder in schwarz ist, was auch immer, hier ist er angeblich
3,2 und hier ist er 1, 3,1 und wir wissen alle, USB 3,1 gibt es gar nicht mehr, alle
die das schreiben sind zu dumm, die Genialität des USB Standards zu verstehen, es gibt kein
USB 3,1 mehr, alles outdated, overrated, Chebaton, aber das ist tatsächlich relativ günstig,
ja Amazon.de, klick mich, das scheint tatsächlich relativ günstig zu sein für 105 ok, eBay,
bei Simbershop 2020 oder bei Mlwcomcom, das sind immer so super seriös klingende eBay-Namen,
Preisentwicklung, wollen wir Preisentwicklung gucken, Preisentwicklung gucken, Preisentwicklung
ist wuhu, so Amazon, da kommen wir bestellen, ich bestelle mir einfach, was hab ich eigentlich
noch alles, 1TB, gibt es die auch mit 2TB, gibt es die auch mit 2TB, na gut 1TB reicht
für Aufnahme, was hab ich denn da bei Amazon noch alles hier im Basket liegen, zeig mal
her, oh das brauch ich noch, das hab ich mir das letzte Mal gar nicht bestellt und den
brauch ich auch noch, den hab ich auch nicht bestellt, die hab ich bestellt, OKS, dann
machen wir hier, Bro Case, warum brauch ich, was ist der Sinn für so ne SSD in den Case
zu haben, ich mein die SSD an sich ist ja stabiler als das Case, wo ist der Sinn, man
weiß es nicht, Fluxstells, ja beste, der Mini Fluxer, guck mal der ist er, der Mini Fluxer,
guck mal, ein Anime Body Pillow, ja brauch ich unbedingt, gibt es sowas auf Amazon.de,
wie heißt ein Body Pillow auf Deutsch Körper Kisten, nee, keine Ahnung, Anime Body Pillow,
girl, oi oi oi, warum, warum hat die 6 Augen, oi oi oi, oi oi, wo ist der Sebaro wenn man
den braucht, das war knapp, war kurz vor Toss, ja ja kurz vor Toss, so, ja kann vorkommen,
muss man die wichtigen Sachen sich auf Amazon angucken, nein ich hab kein Anime Body Pillow,
ich hab aber ein Seitenschläfer Kisten, wisst ihr warum, weil ich 37 bin und alt, wenn ich
zufällig falsch liege tut mir der Rücken weh, so, hast du sinnvolle Ideen was zu programmieren,
also was nützliches, ich hab ja für so eine Python API oder, ok Pains Jam, keine Ahnung,
das muss ja schon ungefähr, muss ja schon ungefähr irgendwie so ne Richtung haben,
ich hab viele sinnvolle Ideen was man programmieren könnte ja, aber nix jetzt so was dich vielleicht
interessiert, du könntest beispielsweise einen Python zu Battlefield Portal XML Converter
programmieren, es gibt hier ne Menge sinnvolle Dinger, aber das dir gefällt weiß ich nicht,
wahrscheinlich, sind Pork, also ich hab die T7 und ich hab das Gefühl die überhit, manchmal
krieg ich nämlich ne Meldung hier, also Fehler schreiben, hab ich irgendwas überlesen, ich
bilde mir an es gab noch irgendeine Frage, aber ich seh es jetzt nicht, lass uns heute
nicht tippen, nee nee, nix, nix gesehen, das Alex hat überhaupt keine Frage, der postet
irgendwas mit der Feuerwehr, ja das ist XML unter der Haube, ja ist es, aber das bringt
dir ja nix, weil du kaum Stellen hast wo du den du was draus drehen kannst, gab doch
keine Frage mehr, ich hab wieder Subscribers übersehen, ich bin verwirrt zu spät schon,
vor neun Minuten, danke schön für den Sub, Pogu, so und irgendjemand hat gepostet, der
hat seine Prüfung bestanden, aber ich find das nicht mehr, irgendwas mit Technik, Prüfung,
ach hier, heute anderen Teil der Operative Professional Prüfung geschrieben, Mitarbeiter
in Teamführung, Pains Cem, ja Operative Professional ist ja diese IHK Weiterbildung, wo ich mich
immer frage ob das jemand macht, aber jetzt hab ich die Antwort, ja das macht anscheinend
jemand, Blah oder Blah Blah, danke für den Sub, Massive Sixhead Subscription hier, ja
nix, einfach gar nix, ich hab gedacht ich geh nochmal on, hast du Nasty Schneider mal
für Battlefield Portal gemacht, immer, ich mach immer, bevor ich irgendwas mach, mach
ich ein Strukturkram, auch wenn ich morgens aufstehe und aufs Klo muss, dann mach ich
vorher ein Strukturkram, weil man weiß ja nie, was da alles passieren kann, wenn es
nicht strukturiert ist, so ein Strukturkram wissen wir alle, ist natürlich ganz wichtig
für so ein Ablauf, nee, haben wir nicht Pepo Shy, warum haben wir Pepo Shy nicht aktiviert,
Moment das muss ich gleich mal nachholen, haben wir keinen Pepo Shy, Pepo Shy das ist
ein, hab ich letztens erfahren, ich verfolge Valorant nicht so, es gibt ein Valorant Female
Team, das Pepo Shy heißt, also jetzt ist Pepo Shy aktiviert, es ist ziemlich limitiert,
man kann sich wirklich viel machen, so, also wie gesagt, ich hab nix großartig vor, natürlich
hab ich mir ein paar Sachen überlegt, wo ich ein bisschen was drüber erzählen kann,
denn hier, wie gesagt erstmal SSD einkaufen, haben wir jetzt gemacht, SSD und der Mini
Fluxer, der wird jetzt abgestellt, Boss Removed, wunderbar, Marx gibt es eigentlich noch irgendwas
Flashbares auf dem Markt, ja, die letzte Flashbare Steckdosenleiste, die ich kenne,
ist die hier, die hab ich nämlich erst vor zwei Wochen gekauft und, Smart, muss man
bestimmt Smart mit eingeben, die hier, die hab ich erst vor, aber die ist eigentlich
zu teuer, aber die hab ich erst vor ein paar Wochen gekauft, die lässt sich noch Tasmota
flashen, haben wir sogar hier live im Stream zusammen gemacht, Hammer, wann lohnt sich
der Black Friday eigentlich, nur bei Amazon und eigenem Zeug, also wenn du zum Beispiel
hier einen, sagen wir mal hier Black, wenn du irgendwie einen HD10 kaufen willst, dann
ist das ganz sinnvoll, jetzt nicht, jetzt ist doof, aber es geht schon in die richtige
Richtung, aber das muss noch billig werden, wenn das mal bei 89 ist oder so, dann kannst
du es kaufen, am besten natürlich noch günstiger, also für Amazon eigene Sachen lohnt sich
das und ich finde, Amazon eigene Sachen, gibt es eigentlich nur Tablets, die sich lohnen,
vor allem wenn man sie danach deploatet und den ganzen Amazon-Campel wieder runterschmeißt,
Fire TV Sticks, wenn man's will, kann man sich kaufen, finde ich jetzt aber persönlich
nicht so geil, die Tablets sind eigentlich das einzige, was sich lohnt und die Tablets
dann halt auch wie gesagt nur deploatet und zwar nur deploatet mit dem Fire Toolbox oder
wie dieses Ding heißt, Fire Toolbox, einfach deploatet, oh mittlerweile ist das rot, ist
auch neu, ich weiß, ich hab bis heute nicht verstanden, warum dieser Typ so eine ultra
hässliche PowerShell Konsolen GUI gemacht hat, anstatt irgendwie was halbwegs ansehnliches,
aber wahrscheinlich kann das nicht besser und ich will mich jetzt auch nicht beschweren,
dass der den Kram hier quasi schon irgendwie drei Jahre maintained. Man kann das auch
manuell machen, ja, aber dann musst du den ganzen Scheiß raussuchen, da hab ich kein
Bock drauf.
Gibt's das auch für Linux, nee, wenn du Linux hast, musst du dir selbst raussuchen,
wobei ich mir nicht sicher bin, ob es da was gibt, musst du dir mal bei XDA gucken, dann
geht das. Kannste über Wine ausführen, ich weiß nicht, wie sieht das mit Wine und USB
Zugriff aus, wenn USB über Wine funktioniert, dann geht das höchstwahrscheinlich auch über
Wine, ja. Doom Swap, danke für den Sub. Keine Ahnung, wie das ist. Habt ihr alle schon
mal ein neues Video geguckt? Wenn nicht, muss ich jetzt ein bisschen Werbung machen für
mein neues Video, ihr könnt euch jetzt mein neues Video angucken nach dem Stream. Wir
haben im Prinzip das gemacht, was ich gestern, vorgestern, gestern, was ich gestern im Stream
gemacht hab, nur etwas anders. Wir haben beispielsweise noch eine Nuke eingebaut und manche Sachen
anders gemacht als gestern im Stream. Ihr findet ja eigentlich den neuen Thumbnail Style,
da hab ich ja hier so mit angefangen, so quasi, so ab hier hab ich ungefähr damit angefangen.
Ich bin halt, ich kann sowas eigentlich nicht, aber nachdem Thumbnail Gestalter so unglaublichst
unzuverlässig sind, ich wart schon wieder seit drei Wochen oder so, bis sich da irgendwelche
Leute melden. Ob trotz Nachfragen, es ist echter Wahnsinn. Also, die kreativen Leute
sind so kreativ, dass sie es nicht schaffen sich zu melden. Ja, aber ich hab's dann geändert.
Das kriegen die Leute schon raus. Wirklich? Naja, soll mir recht sein. Es gibt halt kaum
gescheite Leute, die sowas machen, ich weiß nicht. Was ist eigentlich aus den Leuten
geworden, die Battlefield? Oh, hör mal auf. Alter, hör mal auf. Der erste hat sich irgendwie
nach einer Woche gemeldet, er ist jetzt im Krankenhaus. Gut, kann er nix für. Ich glaube,
der ist ganz gut, mit dem würde ich auch weiter was machen. Dann hat sich noch einer gemeldet,
der hat dann auch was zusammengeschnitten, aber das hat mir überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Das war wirklich nicht so das, was ich mir irgendwie vorgestellt hab. Der hat zwar ein
paar lustige Sachen rausgesucht aus den Streams, aber im Prinzip war da nichts wirklich großartig
dabei. Dabei hatten wir wirklich coole Sachen im Stream. Wann kommt eigentlich Halo raus?
Das muss doch jetzt auch irgendwann sein. Könnte mich mit meinem Outtakes-Video hier,
wie gesagt, ich brauch immer Leute, die Stream-Highlights und so schneiden. Wirklich, du musst das
noch nicht mal umsonst machen. Das muss halt gut sein. Es muss jetzt hier irgendwie nicht
super krass Effekte und Bild in Bild und sonst was, aber das muss halt schon feinfühlig
gemacht sein. Es bringt jetzt nichts da, wie beispielsweise in einem Video, dass man einfach
irgendwie drei Tode nimmt, die zusammenschneidet und dann irgendwie einen Meme drüberlegt
oder so. Dubstep. Also wenn du das machen willst, ohne Scheiß, dann schreibst du entweder
im Discord nochmal oder schreib mir an die Business-Mail, die auf meinem Channel steht
und sag mir, was du haben willst, so für was weiß ich pro Arbeitsstunde oder pro Video
oder so ungefähr. Das muss ja nicht konkret sein. Rick Stonks. Was? Wait a minute, ist
das gerade eben rausgekommen oder? Nee. Was? Nee, das kommt am 8. Dezember. Hä? Ah, der
Multiplayer-Teil. Ach, heute ist ja Xbox-Jubiläum. Stimmt. Ach, ernsthaft? Twitch? Halo? Wirklich?
Tatsächlich. Moment, Moment. Ach, das ist der Channel-Halo, man. Ich hab's nicht gecheckt.
Ich muss auf Halo Infinite, so rum. Halo Infinite ist da. Kann ich das Ganze auch vielleicht
Zuschauer viel wenig und wie kann ich denn hier Kanäle auf Deutsch rausmachen? Geht
das? Ich will keine deutschen Kanäle angezeigt kriegen. Nee, das geht anscheinend nicht.
Tatsächlich. Das ist ja interessant, dass das raus ist. Dann werden sich sicherlich
viele freuen. Spannend. Hätte ich gar nicht gedacht. So, das heißt, das ist... Ich meine,
ich hab die Berichterstattung im Vorfeld ein bisschen verfolgt und ich hab da so rausgehört,
dass viele Leute gesagt haben, ja, es macht es ein bisschen anders. Es ist auch im Kern
der klassische Halo-Multiplay, aber es macht es ein bisschen anders. Halt, dass es eben
halt auch längerfristig monetarisierbar ist und sowas. Also ich bin da wirklich mal gespannt
drauf, ob das klappt. Ja. Und wo kriegt man das? Im Store? Ach komm. Please, gibt's
das nicht auf Steam? Steam, Halo, Infinite? Gibt's das auf... Ach, das gibt's auch auf
Steam. Nice, sehr gut. Die Beta, aha. Die Kampagne kommt am 8. Dezember. Sag mal, wenn
ich die Story schon wieder lese... Ich weiß, das Spiel heißt Halo, aber ist es nicht irgendwie
merkwürdig, dass in jedem oder in fast jedem, es ist ja nicht in jedem, in fast jedem Halo
zufälligerweise irgendwie wieder ein Halo-Ring auftaucht? So, da ist er ja. Wo kommt er
dann auf einmal her? Wir wussten gar nicht, dass es den noch gibt, aber diesmal ist es
der allerletzte Halo-Ring und der ist ganz wichtig und sowas in der Richtung. Nächster
Singleplayer, hoch. Da ist ja noch ein Halo-Ring. Wo kommt der wieder her? Das ist der wichtigste
jetzt, ja. Das ist noch wichtiger als die letzten fünf. Wobei man sagen muss, das ist
tatsächlich nicht wirklich... Das ist nicht immer so. Halo 5 hatte, glaube ich, keinen
neuen Halo-Ring. Halo 5 war ja Cortana, dreht durch. Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, wenn
ich es noch in der richtigen Erinnerung habe. Halo 4, kann ich mich gar nicht mehr dran
erinnern, wenn ich bin so richtig... Ach, keine Ahnung. Guck mal, noch keine Steam-Reviews.
Normalerweise gibt es Steam-Reviews immer. Meistens schon direkt zu Release und dann
sowas sinnloses wie Cortana Big Boops Best Game Ever oder sowas. Das sind typisch die
typischsten sinnlosen Steam-Reviews. Hast du noch eine kleine Review zu Belfilm an Vorrelease?
Ja. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das Video von heute geguckt hast, nämlich das da. Da sage ich
genau das. Das sage ich nämlich. Achtung, ich zitiere mich selbst. Wir müssen das nicht
lang aushalten. Ich habe in Battlefield Portal fast mehr Spaß als in Battlefield 2042 selber.
Die eingebauten Classic-Sachen in Portal selbst sind ja schon ganz nice. Aber richtig Spaß,
ich fand ich das selbst, ich nenne es mal Programmieren von eigenen Spielmodi. Deshalb
bauen wir heute mal oder nennen wir es mal Programmieren oder Skripten. Es ist schwierig
zu sagen, wie ich es genau nennen soll. Wir bauen heute zusammen Nosher Canals TDM mit
Killstreaks. So richtig mit ULV, einer Nuke am Ende, einem Blackbird, Sentry Gun, so was
man sich so unter Killstreaks vorstellt. Natürlich ist Portal noch ein bisschen limitiert. Das
heißt, wir müssen manchmal ein bisschen tricksen. Aber am Ende bekommt ihr auch noch den Code,
dass ihr das alle mal ausprobieren könnt. Und würde mich mal interessieren, könnt
ihr die Kommentare schreiben, was ihr jetzt von dem Spielmodus haltet, den wir hier zusammen
gebaut haben. Und nächste Woche zum richtigen Release des Games kommt dann mein komplettes
Review oder Fazit zu dem Game. Das heißt, wenn ihr es nicht verpassen wollt, dann drückt
jetzt einfach mal den Abo-Button und ich würde sagen, los geht's.
Exzellent. Das könnt ihr übrigens auch auf Twitch machen, wenn ihr jetzt gerade frisch
hier seid. Da muss es nicht unbedingt der Subscribe-Button sein, der Follow-Button reicht natürlich
auch erstmal. Aber so sieht es aus. Ich habe das so geplant, dass ich quasi zum 19. oder
vielleicht am 18. oder so schon, dass der Algorithmus das dann abpickt. Tolles Satz,
dass ich das dann starte. Das Video. So, jetzt habe ich das auch beantwortet. Battlefield
20. Insane sniping. Insane. Ja, wenn du insane snipen willst in 2042 musst du erstmal lernen,
3km vorzuhalten und drüber zu halten. Willst du nur noch eine Woche arbeiten? Das ist ganz
einfach zu erklären, denn, kurz runter scrollen, denn, genau, so sieht es aus, denn ich habe
Urlaub eingetragen schon seit Anfang des Jahres für den kompletten Dezember und mir
ist jetzt aufgefallen, dass ich ja noch 4 Tage Resturlaub habe. Das bedeutet, ich habe
den Tag hier noch eingetragen und dann noch den hier eingetragen und hier nehme ich einen
Tag Kleidzeit. Montag arbeite ich eh nicht. Ich arbeite hier nur 4 Tage in der Woche, genau
und jetzt zack, bam, 19. ist der erste Urlaubstag. Also nein, das stimmt nicht, der letzte Arbeitstag.
Das heißt also quasi, ich muss jetzt noch 1, 2, 3, 4 Tage arbeiten und das beste ist,
morgen muss ich wieder mit der Bahn fahren. Das heißt, wer bei mir auf Twitter am Start
ist, der muss wahrscheinlich morgen wieder etwas Geflame ertragen. Und das blöde daran
ist, dass man an diesem Tag eigentlich nichts macht. Ich weiß nicht, ob das Problem auch
irgendjemand hat, der im vergangenen Jahr oder die vergangenen eineinhalb Jahre hauptsächlich
Homeoffice gearbeitet hat, aber ich finde, der Unterschied von Homeoffice arbeiten zu
man ist vor Ort ist einfach riesengroß. Ich meine, daheim hast du erstmal die ganze
Hin- und Zurückfahrt nicht. Das ist glaube ich jedem klar. Du bist auch, wenn du fertig
bist, bist du fertig. Das ist aber so, du musst dich nicht mit der Bahn umschneiden,
das hat alles Vorteile. Aber selbst, wenn du vor Ort bist, im Prinzip ist es nur sinnloses
Gemiete, sinnloses Geschwätze. Man schwätzt ja nicht mal übermäßig viel, aber du kannst
dich auch nicht richtig konzentrieren, wenn du irgendwas bauen musst. Aber man sich ja
gedacht hat, oh ja, ja ja, für Programmierer sind, also Großotter, ich arbeite ja eigentlich
nicht direkt in der Softwareentwicklung, ich mache auch noch andere Sachen, aber trotzdem,
also da muss man sich nicht konzentrieren. Großraumbüros sind eine super Geschichte
und das ist natürlich ganz besonders konzentrationsfördernd, wenn jemand im Raum sitzt, der laut telefoniert.
Wer kennt es nicht? Und im Prinzip besteht bei mir der Dienstag aus, meeten, meeten, dann
sagt dann irgendwer, ach ja Max, bist du auch mal wieder da, ja wie sieht es denn hier aus,
bla bla bla bla bla, so nächstes Meeting, dann gehe ich irgendwo hin, was fragen, dann
erzählt er mir 20 Minuten was, im Prinzip mache ich Dienstag den ganzen Tag eigentlich
nichts und ich frage mich allen Ernstes, wie ich das früher geschafft habe, mit 4 Tagen
im Büro dort überhaupt was zu machen und ich glaube, realistisch betrachtet ist es
auch so, dass ich da zum größten Teil wahrscheinlich auch nicht wirklich viel gemacht habe. Das
ist mit Homeoffice einfach viel viel besser, du kriegst auch viel mehr durch, die dich
nerven weniger Leute, das ist eigentlich super, naja, ja das kommt ja auch noch dazu, du sparst
dir halt die Fahrzeit, deswegen kannst du zu normalen Zeiten aufstehen und trotzdem halt
auch relativ früh anfangen, ja geht mir genauso, Daily 4 Stunden Streams, na nee so viel nicht,
aber ich mache auf jeden Fall mehr Streams dann, aber das finde ich spannend, dass das
aktuelle Halo schon raus ist, spoiler Leute, hat irgendjemand von euch noch die Story von
Halo 5 im Kopf, ist Cortana eigentlich wieder gefixt und wieder mit am Start jetzt, weil
Cortana ist das beste an Halo, ich hab die Story nicht mehr im Kopf, keine Runde Cringe,
nein, keine Runde Cringe, das ist spannend, ich werde das mal Offstream ausprobieren,
ich bin beim besten Willen kein guter Halo Spieler, dann hat es ja trotzdem für dich
Vorteile, Halo ist aber auch nicht mehr das was es war von der Magnet Wirkung, denkt mal
zurück an Halo 3, Halo 3 war jahrelang auf der Xbox einfach so das Multiplayer Ding,
neben Cod und ein bisschen später dann Battlefield, aber nach Halo 3 kam nichts mehr, ich glaube
nach Halo 3 haben die nicht sogar, nee Reach war das letzte von Bungie, war Halo Reach
noch von Bungie, ja Halo Reach war glaube ich das letzte Bungie Spiel, richtig genau,
selbst da ging es schon ein bisschen abwärts, auch mit dem Spieler Interesse, also entweder
liegt es daran, dass das Halo Spielprinzip außer Mode gekommen ist oder auch ein bisschen
mit daran, dass Halo eben so diesen Glanz verloren hat der etwas früheren Tage, Halo
3 war das letzte richtig große Halo wo die richtig die Massen noch hinterher geschrien
haben, so nice Halo, es ist quasi Not Stonks gewesen, übrigens was ich vorhin gelesen habe,
was ich auch witzig fand ist, was ich auch lustig fand, dass jetzt wieder überlegt wird
Home Office Pflicht soll zurückkommen, das ist so geil, da werden Sachen abgeschafft
und 3 Monate später stellt man dann fest, hoch, wer hätte nur damit rechnen können,
es ist jetzt Winter, das wusste man gar nicht, wie bei der Bahn, da kommt das auch jedes
Jahr komplett überraschend, dass es jetzt kalt wird, so was, es ist September, November,
Dezember, da wird es ja kalt, nee das kann eigentlich, das kommt jetzt, das kommt doch
nie vor, so Impfzentren zu gemacht, jetzt werden sie wieder aufgemacht, WTF, so als
könnte man das, als könnte man das alles nicht im Vorfeld überlegen, die 4 Feinde
der deutschen Bahn, Frühling, Sommer, Herbst und Winter, ja das finde ich lustig und das
hier fand ich auch witzig, wo ich die Überschrift heute gelesen habe, Profitgier der Filmindustrie
stärkt illegale Kopierszene und wisst ihr was ich mir dabei gedacht habe, das erste
was ich mir dabei gedacht habe ist, die lernen es einfach nicht, die, die, die, die können,
ich verstehe es nicht, die lernen es einfach nicht, mein Battlefield 2042 Server ist down,
ich habe überhaupt kein Battlefield 2042 Server, der abseilen sein sollte, wie kann
der down sein, ich habe noch nicht mal einen gestartet, du kannst mit dem Code einen hosten,
wenn du willst, glaube ich, ich habe keine Ahnung wie diese Codes funktionieren, ich
habe den einfach mal drunter gehauen, aber hier, die lernen es einfach nicht, ich meine,
die meisten Leute von euch werden nicht am Start gewesen sein, sagt euch Napster noch
was, ich glaube den Namen kennt man heute noch, aber wirklich dabei waren wahrscheinlich die
wenigsten, Napster, gibt es die überhaupt noch, Napster, gibt es die noch, hey das Logo
ist noch gleich geblieben, aber sonst, war Napster illegal, aber sowas schon, Napster
wird illegal, äh nein, nein, nein, Aldi, lul, alter, das ursprüngliche Napster kennen
die wenigsten wahrscheinlich, das war eines der ersten Musik P2P Tauschbörsen und das
war die Zeit, wo die Musikindustrie damals noch gesagt hat, Streaming, das ist ja hier
böse, da entgehen uns, weil die haben ja gesagt, jeder Download wäre ein verpasster CD-Kauf,
was ja Schwachsinn ist und die Leute haben gesagt, Musikindustrie, ich will daheim sitzen,
auf den Knopf drücken und vorne meinem Rechner den Kram abspielen und die Musikindustrie
hat gesagt, nein, nein, nein, nein, wir wissen das besser als ihr, ihr wollt das nicht,
ihr sollt gefällig CD's kaufen und die Leute haben gesagt, nein, ich will keine CD's kaufen,
ich will den Scheiß streamen und wenn ich das nicht bei euch kriege, zu irgendwie dem
normalen Preis und zu normalen Release-Zeiten weltweit, dann geh ich zu Napster und hol mir
den Scheiß illegal.
So, und das gleiche passiert jetzt hier auch, das kann man immer schön sehen, wenn ein
gewisses Level überschritten ist, was quasi bei den Leuten nicht mehr verhältnismäßig
ist im Kopf, dann gehen sie illegal hin, wir haben in den letzten Jahren einen kompletten
Rückgang davon gesehen, ja.
Die Leute machen jetzt Spotify, seht ihr, kaum gibt es irgendwie sinnvolle Angebote zu sinnvollen
Preisen, wo genug Auswahl an Titeln drin ist, schon machen es die Leute, wer hätte das
so denken können.
Es gab zeitlang Streaming-Dienste, du hast eins, zwei Streaming-Dienste gebraucht, konntest
dir den meisten Scheiß angucken, so, heute wurden 150 Streaming-Dienste für, keine Ahnung,
du brauchst 70 für Musik, 70 für Videos und nochmal zehn, falls du irgendwas lesen willst,
irgendwelche Abos und Streaming-Dienste, dann sagen die Leute, wisst ihr was, dann kommen
sie, dann fangen sie ja mittlerweile wieder mit dem Scheiß an, so nach dem Motto, ah nee,
das kommt jetzt in dem Land zuerst raus, in dem Land kommt es später raus, ach nee, hier
gibt es wieder keine Untertitel, ach nee, hier gibt es eine Originalsprache und da sagen
die Leute einfach, fickt euch, ich lag mir den Kram irgendwo runter, das ist immer das
gleiche und die lernen es einfach nicht und was ich, was ich ja besonders witzig fand
zur damaligen Zeit, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt, Mama, wo ist Papa, äh Kopierschutz,
ja ich weiß nicht, was ich suchen soll, Raubkopierer Werbung, das hier, das hier, so, damals haben
die sich eher gedacht, hey, wisst ihr was, bevor wir den Leuten irgendwie mal einen ordentlichen
Streaming-Surfer geben, machen wir so eine Scheiße hier, ich kriege Anfälle, wenn Kinder
rumschreien, deswegen, ich muss das mal ein bisschen leiser machen, sonst bin ich triggert,
das hätte ich auch nicht lizenziert, vor allem gerecht, wer entscheidet, das hat mich
damals schon immer getriggert, wer entscheidet mit euch gerecht, meinen die ernsthaft im
Gerechtigkeitsgefühl 99% der Leute, ist es gerecht, dass jemand für das Kopieren von
CD's ins Gefängnis kommt, so, also, so Werbung haben die damals gemacht, ähm, um den Leuten
ein schlechtes Gewissen zu machen, so nach dem Motto, jaja, bloß nicht Napster oder was
gab's denn dann sonst noch, äh, was gab's denn noch, LimeWire, ähm, Beershare, alter,
kennt noch jemand Beershare, was das für ein Kack alles gab, ähm, oder, äh, AudioGalaxy
oder sowas, EmuleCasa, genau, diesen ganzen Krempel da, da haben die lieber so dumme Werbung
gemacht, richtig, richtig, gestört, naja, gut, so, jetzt haben wir uns da drüber bisschen
aufgeregt, wunderbar, alles klar, so, und das ist das, was ich gesagt habe, die lernen
daraus einfach nicht, die kriegen es einfach nicht gebacken, ja, pausen war nicht so viel
illegale Seiten, wo man Zeug machen kann, Mods, Blitz, einmal, äh, löschen die ganzen
Seiten, weil das, das ist im Zweifelsfall, da krieg ich dann auch noch Probleme, wenn
hier Leute irgendwie links zu illegalen Seiten posten, ja, alles klar, aber sie lernen sie
einfach nicht, ich bin echt begeistert, wie Lernresistent man sein kann, ach ja, ich hab
die vm gestartet, weil ich gucken wollte, was ich bei AliExpress bestellt hab und vergessen
hab, irgendwas hab ich bei AliExpress bestellt, aha, ist das ein, das ist keine Robbe, was
ist denn das, wer ist biologisch, wer kennt sich hier so biologietechnisch aus, was ist
das, eine Seekuh, messen, wie schlauter Chat ist, exzellent Chat, so, ähm, was hab ich
hier bei AliExpress vergessen, das letzte Mal, hm, nix anscheinend, dann weiß ich auch
nicht, keine Ahnung, da hab ich's vergessen, ich bin begeistert, der Chat ist richtig, richtig
schlau, ich weiß es ja nicht, weil mein Hintergrund ist ja nicht von mir eingestellt, es ist ja
Bing Image of the Day, ich glaub ich bin der einzigen, der Bing verwendet, sonst benutzt
jemand Bing, aber Bing Image of the Day ist das, Toxamonx, danke für den Sub, ich hab
schon wieder die Hälfte nicht gesehen hier, MatrixHD, danke für den Sub, Legion1498,
hier PrimeSub, Poggers, schaff es leider viel zu selten an den Streamszuschauern, bist
ein neulich mal Lieblings YouTuber, schau dich seit 2011, Massive, nice, dass du hier den
Weg hergefunden hast, heute ist aber glaub ich nicht so super spannend, wir schwätzen
ein bisschen dummes Zeug und ich guck mir ein paar Sachen an, DrGo nutzt doch auch Bing
oder nicht, ich dachte DrGo hat irgendeine eigene Search Engine, nutzt DrGo Bing, ach
den mal die haben was eigenes, Spackhack, sieben Monate, Pog, für Bilder, ja ok für Bilder
versteh ich, aber wie gesagt, sind Wish Geschenkgutscheine eine gute Idee für Weihnachten, du bist öfters
da, deswegen geh ich davon aus, die Frage ist G-Bait, und falls die Frage ernst gemeint
ist, nein, Wish ist generell der größte Kack, den man überhaupt benutzen kann, Wish ist
für alle Leute, die zu blöd sind, selbst in China zu bestellen, Wish hat keine Existenzberechtigung,
ernsthaft, ich weiß nicht, warum Wish überhaupt noch existiert, was ist der Grund, warum gibt
es Wish überhaupt noch, für die Memes, ja wahrscheinlich, weil jeder, der wirklich
China Kram haben will und nichts anderes ist ja Wish, kann zu Banggood gehen oder zu Aliexpress
oder zu DHgate oder so, was es noch alles gibt, gibt ja zig Milliarden China Shops,
wo einer so aussieht wie der andere, die China Shops werden ja eh alle vom chinesischen Web
Design Ministerium erstellt, deswegen sehen die sich auch alle so ähnlich, ich mein mir
kann doch keiner erzählen, dass das nicht vom gleichen Web Designer erstellt wurden
diese 3 Shops, das ist doch original der gleiche Kram, approved, die benutzen agiles WordPress,
das ist gar nicht kein WordPress, die Noobs lassen sich gerne Jibane, Gearbest gibt es
auch noch, genau, gibt viele so China Shops, wir bräuchten ein China Commodate, wie nennen
sich die Chinesen denn untereinander, das ist ja eher Russisch, the Commodate China,
gibt es da denn ein Emote, ne, die Aliexpress ist ein Spring Boot, ernsthaft, Java, na gut,
wundert mich nicht, Java ist bei den China Chinesen sehr beliebt, China Commode, ne,
wie nennen sich die Chinesen untereinander, es gibt bestimmt so ein China Emote, das mach
ich dann auch noch rein, wenn wir Commodates haben als Emotes, gibt es bestimmt auch China,
ja mach, tue dir keinen Zwang an, WinniePoo ist doch jetzt verboten in China, ich hab vergessen
warum, China genau, das bräuchten wir eigentlich, so jetzt machen wir die China Seine wieder
zu, da will ich doch eigentlich gar nichts, ich muss mal kurz zur Beruhigung eine Runde
ASCII Quarium anmachen, UK Emote, ja, da fällt mir aber keins ein, oi, warum machst du immer
das Eins in die Adresszeile, weil ich mir das angewöhnt hab, hat keinen tieferen Sinn,
übrigens, Microsoft ist wieder total unfähig, ne, die hatten bei Microsoft letztens so,
.net Konferenz und eigentlich haben die gesagt, wir laden alle Watts auf YouTube hoch, so
und jetzt guckt man, YouTube.net, das ist halt 3 oder 4 Tagen fertig und, da will ich
jetzt net hin, und sie haben nur die Watts hochgeladen bis zum zweiten Tag, die aktuellen
Watts gibt's einfach nicht, ach, jetzt fangen sie an mit dem hoch, ne, machen sie nicht,
also Microsoft ist da richtig Paynes Champ, dabei gab's 4-5 Talks, die ich eigentlich
gucken wollte, Paynes Champ, was hältst du von den tausenden Tech-Stacks, die es mittlerweile
gibt, Oldschool, PHP, das kommt ganz drauf an, also ich bin der Meinung, es hat überhaupt
keinen Sinn, irgendwie, so dem neuesten Zeug dann nachzurennen, sondern man muss sich das
angucken, was sinnvoll für das jeweilige Projekt ist und ganz im Ernst, wenn man gut
PHP kann und ich weiß, wenn man jetzt nicht vielleicht Raw PHP macht, wo man alles selbst
machen muss, sondern fertige Sachen verwendet, die die Fallstrecke ein bisschen, oder sag
man so, die Hürde ein bisschen niedriger machen, sehe ich überhaupt kein Problem,
was ich PHP, Laravel im Backend und JavaScript Frontend, warum nicht, ist überhaupt kein
Ding und die ganzen Tech-Stacks, die haben ja eh nur Basswörternamen, wir haben ja letztens
im Stream den eigenen, wir haben ja unseren eigenen Tech-Stack erfunden, ich habe aber
schon wieder vergessen, wie er hieß, der Chet weiß das bestimmt noch, den Swag, der Swag-Stack
haben wir ja, haben wir im Stream erfunden, Swag-Stack, der Swag-Stack, ich weiß aber
nicht mal, wie er ihn geschrieben hat, ich glaube so, ich glaube so wurde er geschrieben,
ne, SQLite, Vue, ASP.NET Core und das G habe ich schon wieder vergessen, ich glaube, das
Swag-Stack, ich habe schon wieder vergessen, wofür es steht, es war eigentlich nur um
was zu kreieren, was sich cool anhört, Swag-Stack, GraphQL, GraphQL war das, genau, genau, GraphQL,
ASP.NET Core, Vue und SQLite, das Swag-Stack und gerade im Javascript Umfeld kannst du
ja da überhaupt nicht mal Schritt mithalten, also es vergeht ja kein Tag, wo nicht irgendwie
ein super neues gehypedes Javascript Framework rauskommt, da blickt keiner mehr durch, also
Javascript ist wirklich abfuck, was das angeht, oh ich habe gerade noch einen Emote hier gefunden,
was Twitch mittlerweile nicht mehr haben will, beziehungsweise nicht Twitch, was bettertwitch.tv
und better und ffz nicht mehr haben will, hier Band, Band Emote habe ich gerade noch
gefunden, wo kommt denn das her, so anstößiges Zeug, warum habe ich denn hier so was in meinem
Board drinnen, es wird gerade aufgefallen, dass es hier noch drinnen ist, das wurde mittlerweile,
das wurde mittlerweile gelöscht, es wurde noch mehr gelöscht, ich habe hier richtig
Rare Emotes mittlerweile drinne, Zulul habe ich zum Beispiel auch noch drinne, Zulul oder
oder PogChamp, nee wo habe ich den PogChamp, habe ich den originalen PogChamp noch drinne,
wo bestimmt, Band Emotes, also wie gesagt, ich bin der Ansicht, man sollte das nehmen,
was man gut kann und was zu dem jeweiligen Projekt passt und der Rest ist eigentlich
zweitrangig, ach die machen mittlerweile sogar Werbung in Whistle Studio für Whistle Studio,
das ist aber nett, dass man Bescheid weiß, Showidee, Techsack oder Shitcoin, ja das
könnte mittlerweile echt alles sein, habt ihr das mitbekommen mit der Squid Game Coin
oder wie dieses Ding hieß, wo der in Anführungsweise Erfinder dann mit irgendwie, was weiß ich,
wie viel 100.000 abgehauen ist, das ist der, die Leute sind so blöd, ich checke es einfach
nicht, ich checke es einfach nicht, wisst ihr, es gibt Leute, die sind allen Ernstes
hier drauf reingefallen, die sind da wirklich drauf reingefallen, diese ganze Show, die
hat so krass nach Scam geschrien, wie der Typ schon auf die Bühne ist, wie der Typ
schon auf die Bühne gekommen ist, wirkt das irgendwie in irgendeiner Weise seriös, wirkt
das irgendwie so seriös, wirkt das irgendwie so, als möchte ich da mein Geld reinbuttern,
es ist unglaublich, wie einfach sich die Leute bescheißen lassen, der war auch Opfer, ja
das glaube ich ja sogar, aber trotzdem, wie kann man sich da so verarschen lassen, das
schreit doch Scam, hat irgendjemand das jetzt gesehen, hat es gedacht, das ist aber mal
eine seriöse Investitionsmöglichkeit, ich glaube, denen gebe ich jetzt mal 50.000 Euro,
da ist bestimmt kein Scam, nein, nein, nein, nein, wer, wer, also keine Ahnung, ich weiß
nicht, was mit den Leuten los ist, ja wenn es mal reicht, schau dir den Windows 95 Launch
Dance an, ne, ne, das ist cringe, oder du kannst ja auch den This is Windows 386, wo diese
Sekretärin dann anfängt zu singen vorm Rechner, weil sie Windows 386 hat, ne, ne, das muss
nicht sein, Faxgeräte, Bundestag, was, die Faxgeräte sollen weg, ernsthaft, das ist
ja, das ist schon wieder outdated, dann hat man festgestellt, zu Corona-Zeiten braucht
man immer noch Faxgeräte, weil wie soll man denn Corona-Zahlen übertragen ohne Faxgeräte,
das geht auch gar nicht, das ist komplett ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit, welche Sprachen
kannst du eigentlich, ach keine Programme, ach so, ja eigentlich nur Deutsch und Englisch,
es gibt böse Zungen, die behaupten, ich kann auch kein Englisch, aber ich würde sagen
Deutsch und Englisch, bisschen hessisch vielleicht noch, ich kann Brötchen bestellen auf Portugiesisch,
sonst kann ich nix, ach so, ich kann, ich kann, ich kann Beleidigungen auf Niederländisch,
aber ich glaube die Beleidigungen sind mittlerweile TOS und die kann ich hier nicht sagen, weil
die, weil die wahrscheinlich Minderheiten diskriminieren oder so auf Niederländisch
und das, das sage ich jetzt hier lieber nicht, das habe ich mal irgendwo aufgeschnappt und
ja, ich kann beleidigen, ich kann Leute beleidigen auf Niederländisch, ich kann Brötchen bestellen
auf Portugiesisch und ich kann Deutsch und Englisch und so die üblichen Russen und Franzosen
Flames aus Online Games, ja klar, BitConnect Remix, ach ne, bloß nicht, das gibt es bestimmt,
das gibt es bestimmt, wieviel haben die, ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, für manche ist auch
PayPal E-Bahn Aktualisierung seriös, ja ich habe letztens eine, eine Scam SMS bekommen,
ihr DHL Paket ist jetzt bereit und da dachte ich erst so Huch, was denn das und dann habe
ich die Uhr gesehen, die Uhr, Moment wo habe ich mein Handy, ich sage euch mal, ich sage
euch mal, wie die Uhr angefangen hat, sehr, super seriös, super seriös, nein ich will
das Update nicht installieren, MonkaS ist jetzt fast iOS Update angeschmissen, ne, Moment
hier, wo habe ich denn, Scam SMS, hier, also Scam SMS, wir haben versucht ihr Paket zuzustellen,
prüfen sie hier den Status und dann kommt eine Uhr, ladytittytupfer.com, ich glaube
auch, dass DHL unter ladytittytupfer bestimmt ihren Paketstatus anbietet, klickt drauf,
wenn du draufklickst, dann fängst du dir gleich irgendwelche Viren ein, weil das auf
dem Smartphone mit aktuellen Patches natürlich deutlich schwieriger ist, die geben sich
keine Mühe, ne, die hätten wenigstens mal einen Shortlink verwenden können oder so,
das Schlimme ist, da fallen Leute drauf rein, da fallen Leute drauf rein, maxbestesenglisch,
ja zeig mal her, seriöser genannt ist es hier irgendwie Default Comparisons, Englisch,
ja ich sag euch kein Englisch, also Schwäbisch wäre mir nicht bekannt, dass ich Schwäbisch
irgendwie dabei hätte, ich hatte mit Schwaben nichts zu tun, außer dass ich während meiner
Ausbildungszeit da öfters mal war und da hab ich festgestellt, dass Ulm die unfreundlichsten
Busfahrer auf der Welt hat, vielleicht hab ich ja in Ulm auch zufällig damals schon
Ello Tricks getroffen und wir wissen es beide nicht, aber Ulm ist wirklich eines der, weiß
ich nicht, also Ulm ist wirklich die Stadt, wo ich am wenigsten jemals wieder hin möchte,
ja zum Glück, ich mein, die ganzen Scam-Anrufe und SMS und sowas, die zielen ja gerade eben
auch auf die Generationen, sagen wir mal, über 60 ab, unter anderem, also generell
auf Leute, die technisch nicht so bewandt sind, also hätte meine Oma oder mein Opa
eine SMS gekriegt, wo sowas drin steht, die hätten das wahrscheinlich angekriegt, wobei
meine Oma und mein Opa, die wären dafür gar nicht anfällig gewesen, weil die hatten
sowas modernes wie ein Smartphone nicht mal, mein Opa hätte ohne Probleme eins haben können,
das gab es da schon, aber der wollte nicht, da wurde das Rechenzentrum, ja genau, ja genau
und Generation Z, was kommt eigentlich nach Generation Z, kommt da Generation A wieder,
die fallen dann eben auf so Sachen hier rein oder eben auf Generation AA, was kommt, what's
after Gen Z, Alpha, siehst du, so sieht es aus, jetzt müssen wir wieder was gelernt,
wir fällt übrigens gerade noch ein, weil ich hier die Steckdose auf habe, wir müssen
die noch flashen, ich hab noch 4 Stück hier liegen, ne stimmt nicht, 3 Stück noch, die
wir nicht geflasht haben, weil ich hab im letzten Stream gesagt, wir flashen die dann
später und ich glaube später ist nie eingetreten, also die liegen hier noch ungeflasht rum,
müssen wir bei Gelegenheit auch mal machen, aber Steckdosen leisten Flashen beste, es
ist immer noch später, genau, später ist dehnbar, was machen eigentlich die Github
Trends, was machen eigentlich, lass uns mal ganz kurz in die Github Trends reingucken,
das ist Trending, mal schnell drüber scrollen, alles klar, die China-Chinesen sind am Start,
Open Source SDK Instant Messenger, das muss man unbedingt was Neues erfinden, es gibt
ja noch nichts zum Instant Messenger, Instant Messenger ist ja sowas, da gab es noch nie
was und gibt es ja auch nie was für, ich weiß nicht warum alle immer so viele Instant Messenger
Zeug sich ausdenken, ich mein muss ich mal überlegen, wir sind ja schon relativ weit
gekommen seit ICQ und AOL Messenger, aber nicht jede Entwicklung in diesem Sektor war
zum besseren, was bringt euch smarte Steckdosen eigentlich, mir fällt absolut keine wie ich
eine Steckdose als Verbraucher aussehen vielleicht für eine Lampe zum Beispiel oder für die
Heizung oder für den Heizlüfter oder für irgendwie Beleuchtung im Schlafzimmer oder
wenn du was im Keller hast, was du regelmäßig neu starten willst oder wenn du was im Keller
hast, wo du sagst, hey das muss ich nur einmal im Monat einschalten oder so, da gibt es
doch jede Menge Sachen, ich glaube, ich glaube, smarte Steckdosen leisten oder für 3D Drucker,
was auch immer, also ich denke mal smarte Steckdosen leisten dürften eigentlich die
Smart Home Geräte schlechthin sein, mit denen fast jeder irgendwas sinnvolles anfangen
kann.
So, also was haben wir denn hier schönes, was trennt ihr denn diesen Monat auf Shithub,
HashLibsArtEngine, alles klar, Telegram, QuestDB, wisst ihr was ich mir denke zu den ganzen
Datenbankdingern, die es so gibt und ich tue jetzt wahrscheinlich einigen unrecht, weil
das da sicherlich coole Sachen gibt, aber vollkommen egal, ob es so bekannte Sachen
sind wie MongoDB oder sowas hier in der Richtung, in der Regel nimmst du Postgres und im Zweifelsfall
Postgres mit irgendwelchen, wie heißt das, Addons, Plugins, ich weiß gar nicht, wie das
bei Postgres heißt oder irgendwas, was mittlerweile standardmäßig drin ist und du fährst eigentlich
in der Regel ganz gut.
Kennst du schon das, Workplace.com, Facebook für Workplace, nein, kenn ich nicht, Next.js
React Framework, AniCL, ah, guck mal hier, da ist was für die Weeps unter uns, CLI-Tool
to Browse and Play Anime, jawoll, endlich, aus welchen, aus welchen Quellen holt das
diese Dinger denn, das ist doch bestimmt nicht rein legale Streaming-Anbieter oder?
Ne, ich kann AniCL eigentlich installieren, weil wenn ich das starte, dann ist das Monka
Toss und ich werde im Zweifelsfall noch gestrikt, das muss nicht sein, Tokenlist, was auch immer,
XMRIG, auch Bitcoin trendet mal wieder, war eine Weile nicht drin, ist doch irgendwas
spannendes dabei, super Fast Compiler, äh, was, ich kann Rust jetzt zu JavaScript kompilieren
oder was, was, aber warum, examples, ich habe keine Ahnung wofür es gut ist, es ist
ein JavaScript-Compiler in Rust, ah, ich kann JavaScript programmieren und der kompiliert
es dann, ok, das ist wenn ich JavaScript verstehe, wenn ich JavaScript-Native-Anwendungen machen
will, also im Prinzip, wenn ich nur JavaScript ohne irgendwelche großartigen Library-Geschichten
verwenden will, wobei die meisten JavaScript-Libraries, die rein JavaScript sind gehen, aber mit Node-Geschichten
ist dann wahrscheinlich schon wieder vorbei, ja, warum nicht, willst du Halo Infinite streamen,
wahrscheinlich nicht, ich bin ziemlich schlecht was Halo angeht, aber ich gucke es mir auf
jeden Fall an und wenn es mir bock macht und ich vielleicht ein bisschen besser bin, dann
kann ich es auch mal streamen, OS X KVM, das haben wir schon mal ausprobiert, das ist wirklich
cool, hier hat einer ein KVM, only commercial paid, what the fuck, darf man dafür überhaupt
Geld kassieren, Apple sagt doch, du darfst glaube ich Mac gar nicht virtualisieren, das
ist bestimmt allein schon Toss für Fragen danach, das haben wir aber glaube ich mal
ausprobiert, das war wirklich ganz cool, dass wir dann Mac in der VM hatten, ne, ne, wir
haben es mit VirtualBox unter Windows gemacht, wie lange hast du Urlaub, ich habe Urlaub
vom neunzehnten bis zum dritten, vierten, bis zum vierten, also ist ein bisschen, CubeSphere,
Container, Platform Tail, da gibt es auch jeden Tag irgendwas neues, YOLO V5, da weiß
ich zur Abwechslung mal, was es ist, das ist Objekterkennung in Bildern, so eines der bekanntesten
eigentlich, YOLO, steht für you only look once, alles klar, ist nichts spannendes dabei
diesen Monat muss ich ehrlich sagen, guck mal diese Woche, wie viele Mail Accounts hast
du und wie organisierst du die, oh ich habe viele Mail Accounts, ich organisiere die gar
nicht großartig, ich habe einen Passwortmanager, da steht alles drin, das wollte ich übrigens
gar nicht anklicken, ich habe einen Passwortmanager, da steht alles drin und in der Regel weiß
ich so halbwegs für was und für was ich welchen Account benutzt habe und im Zweifelsfall ist
es in der Browserhistorie drin, warum eigentlich nur eine Woche arbeiten, weil ich dann Urlaub
habe, ich habe Urlaub ab 19., also ich muss jetzt noch eins, also Montag, also heute arbeite
ich, also Montags arbeite ich ja prinzipiell nicht, ich muss jetzt noch 1,2,3,4 Tage arbeiten
und dann habe ich bis 4. Januar Urlaub, Pock, so was trendet heute, äh this week, Doggecoin
trendet, PowerShell, IGIT, warum trendet PowerShell, warum, was machen die, warum denn so was,
ich meine PowerShell an sich ist eine coole Sache für Windows Automatisierung, als interaktive
Shell finde ich es nicht schön, na gut, ich verstehe, dass es trendet, die Windows Leute
haben lange nach rauf gewartet, dass sie auch mal eine brauchbare Shell bekommen, ja sonderlich
spannende Sachen trenden da diesmal aber nicht, Rastic für Backups ist tatsächlich ganz
nice, Flutter trendet, ich habe übrigens bis heute nicht verstanden, warum Flutter
unbedingt Dart verwenden muss, warum kann Flutter nicht Go verwenden, weil das ist auch
von Google und Go ist mit Sicherheit die verbreitere Sprache und hat mit Sicherheit mehr Libraries
als Dart, nö ist ja langweilig, trendet ja gar nichts spannendes.
So, ja gut, ähm, machst du gerade Werbung für deine Seite, könnte das sein?
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das liest sich jetzt aber doch schon ganz leicht offensichtlich
nach Werbung, aber meinetwegen, heute, heute will ich mal nicht so sein, lasst, lasst,
lasst stehen Leute, lasst stehen, lasst stehen, komm ich bin sogar mal so nett, ich guck mal
nach was es ist, aber wahrscheinlich gehts nicht über die Suchmaschine raus, weil wer
weiß wo ich dann da lande, ah das ist quasi so eine, so eine GitHub Alternative für wenn
man kein Geld ausgeben will, aber warum, was ist da, ok, da musst du uns das jetzt aber
auch verkaufen, was ist der Vorteil versus GitHub und warum sollte ich das verwenden
anstatt, wenn ich ganz super viel Wert auf Privatsphäre lege für eine selbst installierte
setze XY Software ein oder warum soll ich auch das eher verwenden als GitLab?
Jetzt musst du es uns ein bisschen schmackhaft machen, aber eigentlich keine Lust auf React
Native, aber bei Flutter finde ich, ja geht mir ähnlich, also ich bin ja der Ansicht
dass, also kann man sich wohl streiten, es ist erstens Microsoft schuld, dass wir heute
mittlerweile so viel Elektronen Anwendung ertragen müssen und leider ist es so, das einzig sinnvolle
Crossplatform GUI Framework ist tatsächlich mittlerweile Elektron, Qt ist C++ und dementsprechend
schon mal Müll, Flutter ist auf dem Desktop noch nicht gut genug am Start, Maui unterstützt
kein Linux, es gibt leider nichts außer Elektron und das ist wirklich sehr pains champ, ok
es ist also, ja ok, da kann ich aber auch, ich muss sagen das stört mich jetzt persönlich
nicht so lange es gut funktioniert, aber dann könnte ich auch GitLab nehmen und es halt
backt bei einem Verein mit dem Ziel Open Source Software in Deutschland zu fördern,
ach das ist ein deutsches Projekt, ok das ist zum Beispiel was wo ich sage ja, das lasse
ich mir gefallen, wenn man deutsche Open Source Software fördern will warum nicht,
ja ok, ok verstehe, Non-Profit, was läuft da unten drunter, ist das was eigenes oder
ist das irgendein, ah hier, das ist quasi GTHS Service oder wie darf man das sehen,
ja das habe ich bei mir nämlich lokal auch laufen, dachte mir kam mir irgendwie bekannt
vor, C++ triggert mich, Microsoft meine ich, ja das ist Elektron, Elektron ist, ja das
Elektron ist die Chrome Browser Engine plus Node.js und wenn du da ein Hallo Welt Programm
startest, dann brauchst du erst mal 300 MB RAM, aber gut RAM haben wir ja heute genug
Daily Driver Linux naja, ihr wisst meine Meinung dazu, ihr wisst dass ich Linux Fan bin und
mit Linux mein Geld verdiene, aber für mich ist die beste Kombination immer noch Windows
und Linux VM, vielleicht wird das mal durch WSL abgelöst, mal gucken und ich finde es
immer noch sinnvoller Linux unter Windows zu virtualisieren als Windows unter Linux,
dementsprechend einfach das besten aus beiden Welten nehmen und nicht irgendwie sich das
Leben schwer machen von Leuten die quasi sagen man muss das eine verwenden und das
andere ist scheiße, einfach immer das Tool nehmen was für die jeweiligen Anwendungszwecke
am sinnvollsten ist, ja das wäre nice, naja wisst ihr was wir gucken uns auch mal ein
paar Videos an, was haben wir denn hier zu bieten, ich habe einfach ein paar random Videos
aufgemacht die ich mir auf dem Handy zum später gucken gespeichert habe, was haben wir denn
hier, Homemade Catfeeder 3D Printed, alles klar, Dear Dice please listen, ok ok, das
würde mir empfohlen, das können wir uns tatsächlich mal geben, Raspberry Pi Zero, gut da haben
wir uns eigentlich letztes Mal schon angeguckt, das müssen wir uns nicht nochmal anschauen,
wir wissen dass der Raspberry Pi Zero 2 schneller ist, weil er die CPU vom 3er drin hat und dementsprechend
4 Kerne oder waren es 2 Kerne und 4 Fakekerne, ne ich glaube 4 richtige Kerne, 10 Wege um
besserer Entwickler zu werden, oh ich glaube das ist jetzt ein bisschen zu langweilig, was
ist das hier, oh mehr LEDs zeig her, LEDs ich brauch LEDs, das ist wieder, das ist WLED,
das ist 100 pro WLED, was da unten drunter läuft, die Frage die sich mir bei mir immer
so was stellt ist, warum, ich mein mag zwar cool aussehen, aber warum, der Vorteil von
irgendwelchen 3D getruckten Lampen und LED Ketten, das verstehe ich ja noch, aber warum
ein LED Würfel, wahrscheinlich weil es geht, ne wenn das Arduino ist dann ist es kein WLED,
schön 1 Ampere, oh die ziehen definitiv mehr, das sind ja 16 mal 16 mal 16, da kann ich
doch bestimmt 16 hoch 3 einfach rechnen oder, das sind 4096 LEDs, das zieht um einiges
mehr als ein, wahrscheinlich sind das auch noch 5 Volt LEDs, das braucht, boah da brauchst
du ja das brutalste Netzteil dafür, vielleicht sind das auch 12 Volt LEDs oder noch mehr,
keine Ahnung, aber wenn du 4095 LEDs, du brauchst mehrere Netzteile, glaube ich anders da kommst
du da gar nicht hin, also wenn du wirklich 4095 LEDs, sodass du es auch ordentlich siehst,
alles versorgen willst mit einem Netzteil, 5 Volt LEDs mit einem Netzteil, das Ding muss
ja, was weiß ich da brauchst, 80 Ampere Netzteil 5 Volt oder sowas, dass das ordentlich funktioniert,
vor allem werden dann die dünnen Kabels bisschen warm, könnte ich mir vorstellen, das kann
ja so nicht nur zweck der Sache sein, was ist denn so das stärkste, gibt es 5 Volt 100
Ampere, oh das gibt es tatsächlich, du hättest so mit 200, kann auch durchaus sein, ich habe
jetzt einfach irgendwie irgendwas mal gesagt, was viel ist, Power Supply, ne steht nicht
da, der hat ein Github, stand da was von Github, hier, ach ne das sind die Files, also was
das zieht, wird mich echt mal interessieren, wie gesagt vielleicht 100 200 Ampere, gibt
es 5 Volt 200 Ampere Netzteile, was braucht man da für Kabel, was jetzt mal ernsthaft,
ich hab davon ja, so Elektronik Sachen sind ja eh nicht so komplett meins, was für ein
Kabel brauche ich denn überhaupt, dass ich da 200 Ampere drüber machen kann, oh bei
AliExpress, oh das ist natürlich die beste, ich glaube der Ort an dem ich mir das kaufen
will ist definitiv AliExpress, Mikrocontroler, oh nein, please nicht das Mikrocontroller
Forum, monkaS, wetten die Antworten sind unter aller Sau, oh ne, geht schon los, das ist das
schlimmste Forum was es gibt alter, was 14, 14 Quadrat Millimeter, das bedeutet ein 1,5
Zentimeter großes, ne Moment, wie viel Millimeter sind Zentimeter, doch, doch oder, 10 Millimeter
sind ein Zentimeter, das ist ja nicht wie Millisekunden, achso da hab ich, aber ein 1,4 Zentimeter
dickes Kabel, das ist ja, das ist ja sag mal mal so, das ist kleiner Finger dick das Kabel,
du brauchst nen Kabel wie mein kleiner Finger, oder nicht, ja das stimmt aber ich muss es
ja irgendwo ans Netzteil anschließen, also zumindest am Netzteil brauch ich das, Leitungsquerschnitt
berechnen, exellent, Kommentarfunktion geschlossen, oh ne, please jetzt nicht, nur noch eine Woche
arbeiten, ich muss mal kurz gucken ob mein neues Video noch gut ankommt, ja ja, ja kommt
gut an, ich hab es erst vor ein paar Stunden hochgeladen 12.000 Views, kann ich mich nicht
beschweren, so gucken wir uns mal irgendwas an, was gucken wir uns den jetzt an, zeigt
mal her, Homemade Cat Feeder, den gucken wir uns jetzt an, selbst gebaute Katzenfütter,
Automatisierung, Stellz, Arduino kontrolliert, jawoll, auf gehts, das müssen wir jetzt angucken,
Hacker News, ja da war heute nix spannendes.
Hey guys, I have two cats, one is named Yoko and the other one is named Johnny and sometimes
we have to call each other Johnny, Johnny, Johnny, Johnny, Johnny, Johnny, Johnny, Johnny,
Johnny, Zack!
Jesus!
funktioniert mit schicko funktioniert das nicht
ok zeig ja das ist sehr laut das ist sehr laut sehr laut überspringen wir jetzt
was meine katze machen würde die wird sich erschrecken sobald das geräusche macht die
würde so machen und abhauen ok wir skippen mal ein bisschen vor
ok das ding auszudrucken das dauert aber dauert wahrscheinlich schon mal zwei tage
bei so groß ist das gar nicht wahrscheinlich vielleicht geht sogar in einem tach die leise
und für weiter auf dieser bau welches die insite big play der und
dies part will rotate inside and control the amount of food that will get out
everything was printed with PLA material and without support a rotator I've used to
parameters 20 percent infill a 0.25 millimeter layer height and 0.4 millimeter nozzle and that's
it for the 3d printed parts okay together with these parts we need to use a servo motor like
this one the mg 195 da könnte ich vielleicht den motor recyceln den ich in diesem
ja wie hießen dieses gerät was wir uns letztens im stream angeguckt haben diesem
automatischen ventil öffnen schließen konstrukt noch drinne habe könnte ich den motor für
irgendwas verwenden noch das was wir kaputt gemacht haben das sieht aus wie das was man
früher in inline skates drinne hatte beste beste leute wenn ihr 3d drucke habt und das und sowas
nicht habt das ist das beste gadget was ihr braucht wenn ihr 3d drucke drucke macht und die
miteinander verschrauben wollte beziehungsweise deckel oder so drauf machen wollte er hieltet
insatz ne ja reddit insatz für 3d print das braucht man passt mal auf das ist massive
big brain sack guten tag everybody moin stefan ja ja guck es euch an guck es euch an
kolben holen und reinschmelzen wie man sieht ja gar nicht man schmelzt das man schmelzt
das einfach rein guck man schmelzt das einfach rein und dann lässt man das kalt werden das zeug
ist wirklich bomben fest ich habe das auch schon öfters verwendet man braucht doch nicht mal ein
loch unten drunter aber ihr solltet das fenster aufmachen weil es ein bisschen stinkt und ihr
solltet nicht ganz so heiß machen das ist wirklich nice also mit dass sie und du kannst
halt danach schrauben und so reindrehen also kriegst viel besser teile miteinander verbunden als wenn
man irgendwelche löscher in 3d print druckt und dann da schrauben durchdreht also das wirklich
eines der besten eines der besten zusätzlichen sachen wenn man 3d drucke hat kostet ja auch
nicht viel kostet ein paar euro das ist richtig park ja was für ein ding warum nicht einfach ntp
das ding kommt doch ins wlan oder? ach nee im moment der arduino nano hat ja gar kein wlan
weil akkubetrieben will man das doch eh nicht machen mit einem motor drin
ich würde da einfach ein esp32 nehmen und ntp machen weil das ding eh ins wlan kommt
also manchmal sind glaube ich die einfachen ansätze die besseren guck
weil da macht er sogar strom dran da macht er sogar strom dran ntp wlan fertig ja das sind
die steine da habe ich auch massig davon was super titte was das das ist ein kleber oder?
ja ja das macht er auch nur jetzt weil er ein video davon macht ich habe mir das auch
schon überlegt ob ich nicht irgendwie meine drucke teilweise ein bisschen schöner machen
soll indem ich sie polieren mache ich nie mache ich nie ich habe das ausprobiert das
funktioniert aber mache ich nicht wozu null ja beste hier sieht man es zack richtig rein
stecken beste also da seht ihr dass die dinger sind wirklich nice und man denkt jetzt das hält
auch nicht aber das zeug schmilzt dann wieder rein weil das ist ja wieder direkt darum und
das zeug ist wirklich kriegt das nicht raus also wenn ihr das raus kriegen wollt da müsst
ihr schon eine schraube reindrehen und an der anderen seite wirklich mit irgendwie schwerem
werkzeug dran irgendwie einspannen und mit drehen oder so also ihr kriegt das definitiv
nicht mit eurer normalen kraft im armen da wieder raus es sei denn ihr seid hier irgendwie
der riesen muskelmann der ansonsten irgendwie auch 200 kilo oder hochhebt oder so meinetwegen
vielleicht aber normalerweise kriegt ihr das nimmer raus und wir tun das selbe für die
bottom part for the electronics case we had four insertion an chat im otte case with screws
we will add the bearings on these holes later once we have the servo motor in place so now
let's hack the servo motor servo motors usually can rotate 180 degrees i want to make this
to rotate without stopping if we open any servo motor we will find some kind of feedback
which usually is just a simple potentiometer so clearly that the motor is always in the
middle position we need to replace this potentiometer with a fixed value resistor so i want to solar
to resist this
hätte jetzt mal ein mini floxer da wird sich das viel viel sauberer wieder anlöten lassen
am ende in a voltage divider configuration and they must have the same value so we have
a middle value in between ich mein nicht dass man dafür wirklich irgendwelches flussmittel
bräuchte ne das ist dafür überhaupt nicht notwendig aber es wird trotzdem meistens
schöner so i soldered them like this to the control pcb so now the dc motor should spin
without stopping when we apply a pwm signal to it is all spinning but there is one more
thing to do if you open the oh so viel kogast one of the gear has one pin and this is used
to restrain the rotation to only 180 degrees so viele kogast hatten wir lange nicht mehr
im stream so we could rotate freely 360 degrees and that's it we can now close back the motor
and here i have it connected to the arduino and the potentiometer so as you can see i
can still control the rotation direction but the servo will now rotate without stopping
ok so now get the m3 threaded rod and cut it to around 20 cm if needed we can cut it
shorter later we can screw this on the servo motor to fix it in place i will also add
some entry nuts and tie them to the motor you could even apply some glue if you want
immer schön heiß moment ist es überhaupt heißkleber macht er da some glue if you want
you could even apply some glue if you want so eher so als sekundenkleber oder sowas
ist es ist es der titty kleber den er eben gezeigt hat mit dem tollen namen
im zweifelsfall also es gibt es gibt aber eine grundsätzliche regel wenn
was nicht hält einfach heißkleber drauf als kleber ist die lösung für sehr viele
probleme and the bearing and insert this entire setup inside of the plastic part and measure
where that nut should be so the bearing will fit exactly oh guck mal wie gut das passt
inside of the part and when you find a perfect position i add two more nuts and tie them to
the bearing außer deine beziehung weiß ich hast du mal ausprobiert also ich hab da große erwartung
immer in heißkleber als kleber hilft für fast alles now that the bearing is in place all is
left to do is to add the feeder separator in between so place that feeder inside till you can see
the insertion nuts to the hole so now we add a threaded rod and rotate it till the screw will
get on the other side and on this other side we add another nut and tied it to the feeder
inside so it won't get loose you could also add so man aber ganz schön viel geschraubt ich
mag das ja wenn man 3d drucke mit ordentlich stabilen sachen kombiniert vieles 3d gedruckte
ist halt oftmals ein bisschen wackelig vor allem wenn halt bewegliche teile 3d gedruckt sind die dann
ineinander greifen ja ich habe jetzt zum beispiel schon leute gesehen die also sieht man auch in
youtube videos die drucken dann zahnräder aus dem 3d drucker und machen die ineinander und das ist
mir nichts also ich finde manchmal haben so metallteile schon ihre daseinsberechtigung
an die second bearing we could add to more nuts and tighten them so dass es langfristig eben
funktioniert und die other side we can also screen place the servo motor using entry nuts
and insertion that we have added before now the feeder mechanism is ready and as you can see we
can now rotate the feeder but after some tests I realized that we also need this part in place
and we use this part so not all the food would get on top of the rotating feeder because that
will block it in place like this we can control the flow of food so get this part and 3d printed
wackelt ich sehe es genau dass es wackelt also warum er sich die mühe mit der batterie und der
uhr macht verstehe ich nicht wie gesagt esp 32 nehmen ntp wlan fertig zumal das e ans netzteil
anschließt ist connected to the servo and the real-time clock module and everything is supplied
with 5 volts from the buck converter i also want to add three push buttons so we can change the time
you can also save the battery so falling the schematic i connect everything to a prototyping pcb and add
the arduino nano through hole pains champ outdated overrated so for the craft it is of course a
great story but if you follow youtube videos they tell you that you have to order some ready-made
putzding bei bcb way oder sonst was dir schon irgendwelche fertigen boards bestellen nee hat
der wlan die die die arduino dinger also die die älteren arduino dinger haben alle keinen wlan aber
es zwingt ihn ja keiner arduino zu verwenden in die rtc module ich weiß dass die batterie zum
zum ur modul gehört aber man könnte sich das alles sparen indem man einfach was wlan fähiges
nimmt weil man sehr eh schon in den steck vorzusteckt wlan ntp fertig i get the buck converter and i
soldered the 5 volts connection als usv nee mit der batterie kannst du den motor gar nicht betreiben
on the back then i added to the pcb to supply the digital parts hat eigentlich keinen sinn
on one side of the electronics case i made a hole and i will add a jack connector like this one for
the supply und wenn internet weg ist und wurde von aus fungel die kratz ntp ist ja nicht irgendwie
so dass das instant out of sync ist du rufst dir per ntp ab und süngst dann konstant und wenn
ein internet mal zwei drei tage weg ist selbst dann ist es nicht wirklich out of sync überhaupt kein
problem i also make another hole on top and i pass the server wire to this hole i make the
connections and fix the pcb inside of the case hat der sp nicht sogar eine clock in der clock
on board der sp 32 doch der hat glaube ich sogar eine clock on board weil du kannst ja deep sleep
timer machen und sowas hat die push buttons like this one here and i soldered wires to each for
ground and then i connect them to the arduino so now i could close the case but first we need to
upload vielleicht wollte das gerne selbst machen im arduino keine ahnung using the ds 32 32 library
we get the real time and we store this time and the feeding time on the eeprom memory so even if i
unplug the feeder we will still have the schedule saved onto the memory die on board lock wäre ihm
nicht genau genug ok ich weiß nicht ob das wichtig ist für die katzen dass sie zur millisekunde genau
gefüttert werden but we can select the portions of who to serve between one and ten fifteen twenty
and back to one and using another push button we can select the time interval in hours from one to
twenty four and using the third button okay das muss man sich nicht angucken ich will eigentlich
sehen wie es funktioniert and when we get to that time we spin the motor for so long according to
the portions and that's it we also send some notifications with the buzzer using analog right
kein c++ 20 style painstamp und der macht es richtig der übertreibt sich mit c++ weil
sobald du anfängst wirklich c++ features zu verwenden dann wird sie nach kurzer zeit auf
den kick skin i finally decided to add a display as well leute ich habe die idee warum überhaupt ntp
und warum überhaupt in the real-time clock einfach einen gps empfänger dran genauere zeit als über
gps kannst du gar nicht holen einfach gps empfänger dran und urzeit beste so it will be easier to see
the portions and the time so i connect this to the ice crazy pains on a4 and a5 include in place on
the plastic case i would change the design of the case so it will already ah da macht sogar
bedienung über knöpfe da dran ok das ist big brain übrigens das ist ein weiterer grund warum
man esp 32 viel besser wäre wenn im esp 32 könntest du dir nämlich ins wlan hängen und das ganze über
den web interface einstellen anstatt über irgendwelche knöpfchen but like this we can now see the
portions and the time and not rely on the buzzer notification dann nehmen wir doch gleich ein atom
oren modul naja es gibt sehr viele also zeitzeit sync dinger die über gps gehen also selbst wenn du
eine ordentliche selbst wenn du eine ordentliche uhr nimmst die du so per funk singst das ist auch
nicht genauer als gps also das kann sich kann sie nicht nicht beschweren das ist wirklich super
und so gps modul kostet ja auch nicht viel also ganz ehrlich in dem fall ich hätte sp 32 dran
gemacht jetzt in web interface zum einstellen wie die katz gefüttert werden soll so download the
code from below and upload it to the arduino nano und mit esp 32 könntest du gar noch cloud ai und
blockchain anbinden genau da könntest du nämlich automatisch lernen wann du deine katze am besten
füttern solltest dann wir können die case mit m3 schrauben ai unterstützt wie auf der einen
seite macht da überall so so coole dinge rein und hier wird die schraube einfach so durchgeschraubt
was ist da los an da unten drunter sind wahrscheinlich die dinger das schienlernen
kette wieder als nächstes wollen mich ein 50 billar pressing the first button we can change
the portions glaube das sind zu wenig data points kein problem einfach genug diagonal
skalieren dann geht das und daily scrum nicht vergessen und wenn wir get to that time dinner
is served and the server will start rotating so ich meine coole coole idee ist das schon aber
ich hätte es anders gemacht meine wird abhauen okay sie würde wegrennen i made this whole here so
we can see the food level and inside we have to glue in place a transparent plastic film so i cut
to size a plastic sheet and glue it in place like this we can see inside of the plastic aber gute
idee gute idee finde ich gut wobei wisst ihr man hätte es jetzt noch etwas machen können
märkte das mit einem ultra schall oder oder laser entfernung sensor könnte man das messen wie
viel der stand ist ist also recommended to add a silica back like this one on top of this top
plate so like this we can absorb the moisture and keep the food dry and that is quite important
so now i can feel the hopper with dry food then we can use the ultra schall fällt aus wegen katze
ja ist vielleicht wirklich das keine gute idee ja hast du recht da rennt sehr direkt weg dabei
aber laser entfernungsmesser geht was die haper i add the ball below the feeder and i set the
time to only 20 seconds in the code just for this test will ja dass die katze sich in auge
aussticht oder was wisst ihr was man machen könnte man könnte wirklich eine waage drunter stellen da
kann man die katze auch gleich noch messen die kann sie gleich noch wiegen ob sie nicht noch
mehr pfiffet geworden ist ja oder genau einfach einfach tatsächlich wagemäßig load cell oder
irgendwas für für gemischt messen ja wobei diese dinger sind ja selten für dauerbelastung gedacht
die werden ja dauer mit dauerbelastung ungenauer wobei ich weiß ja nicht ob katzenfutter als
belastung zählt man könnte sogar sagen wenn man nicht will dass die katze zunimmt kommt nur
dann setzt man ein maximalgewicht das sagt man dann quasi wenn katze nur unter maximalgewicht
ist und da kommt immer nur genau so viel essen raus bis zum maximalgewicht das heißt wenn man
gesagt maximalgewicht fünf kilo und die katze wiegt 4900 da kommt 100 gram essen raus erst wenn
die katze abgenommen hat gibt es wieder so viel essen dass sie dann quasi mit essen auf fünf
kilometerwage kommt ich meine die katze treten steigt ihr aufs dach die mauz die mauz sich so
sehr im flur ein ab wenn da nichts raus kommt und die wird dann auch sauer die haut das ding dann
um und macht kaputt im zweifelsfall so the project works and now my cats will always have food i
will leave this device running while i'm home as well for a few months so i'll make sure it
doesn't fail maybe a future improvement is to make it based on batteries and using batteries so
maybe that would be interesting ich würde es mit wehlein machen aber trotzdem an strom anschließen
wireless mit akku ist ist halt dumm mit einem motor vor allem wenn es mehrfach am tach sich bewegt
das ist kacke das geht so schnell her aber man könnte big brain time machen das in irgendeiner
art und weise aufladen da noch mit irgendwie solar energie oder so aber im haus ist halt doof da
scheint halt nicht die sonne another improvement would be maybe to add some suction ventos like
this one below the support so the feeder will get zeigt er uns jetzt auch noch wie die katzen
das fressen oder aber zum aufladen genau du machst hamster rad daneben die katze muss erst mal
ordentlich rennen und erst wenn der akku voll ist kommt essen raus ich will jetzt ich will
erzählen wie die katze angeht zeige ich die katze auf jetzt katzen wie kacke wait
wir bekommen es noch nicht mal vorgeführt lasse mich raten das hat nicht funktioniert
hat nicht funktioniert hat weit gibt es kacke weite emote kacke weite gibt es kacke weite ja
us versus german players let's find out nein
ok wir gucken uns jetzt noch dieses eine acht minuten video an zu battlefield 2042
hier da ist please listen da bin mal gespannt was er sagt weil danach muss ich auch pennen schon
spät ich glaube die haben ich glaube da ist hat ehrlich gesagt ziemliche zweifel gerade an
ihrer eigenen fähigkeit das sieht man die letzten battlefields über den flieger an
ja das stimmt ich finde es cool dass er battlefield 5 nicht erwähnt hat weil es ja ganz einfach
battlefield 5 wenn man es einem nicht gefällt soll man es nicht kaufen ja da hat er recht
ich habe jetzt von einigen leuten gehört noch ich lese das öfters auf twitter dass die leute
angeblich richtig spaß am wenngarten multiplayer haben das ist eines der wenigen color duties was
ich mir nicht gekauft habe weil es mich so überhaupt nicht gejuckt hat sie aber wie kann
es spaß machen mit spmm spite changing things up wahrscheinlich reverse boosted alle it's
breaking the mold of what previous battlefield games stuck to map size game modes classes
in game gibt ja keine ich mein es hat keinen inhalt das spiel all out warfare hat zwei
spielmodi breakthrough is crap auf der hälfte der maps das andere hat box hoch drei also
ja das video ist so voll dick aufgetragen mit der aussprache her
8 videos ich weiß dass er das nicht meint aber alle mit 8 videos immer ich kenne also
ich habe viele videos jetzt gesehen auch zu diesem thema hier kann aus bdfield 42 angeht
und das hatte klar da waren ein paar blöde kommentare aber das meiste ist eigentlich relativ
sachliche kritik aber viele leute verkraften das einfach nicht für die für also ich hab
hat den Eindruck, dass für viele Leute einfach normale Kritik heutzutage immer automatisch
gleich Hate bedeutet.
Und wenn man das schon immer unterscheiden kann...
Ja, geht mir genauso, Chet, ich hätte mir auch so gewünscht, dass das Game, ich wäre
der glücklichste Gamer gewesen, seit langer Zeit mal wieder, wenn das Spiel richtig gut
gewesen wäre.
Also, gerade die All-out-Warfare-Portionen, der Day One-Patch, der kommt am 19., fixt er
vieles, wo soll ich das wissen, keine Ahnung, ich gehe davon aus, dass ein paar grobe Schnitzer
gefixt sind, aber sag mal so, den Kern des Games, wo es was ja auch viele Probleme hat,
wird er nicht fixen können.
Moment, was?
Warte nochmal mal.
Achso, ja, die Concepts looken gut, ihre In-Game-Menüs in Battlefield 7, looken gut, ihre In-Game-Menüs
in Battlefield 7, looken nicht gut.
Ich finde, Voice-Chat ist eine coole Sache, ja, aber es ist so inkonsequent oder so undurchdacht.
Voice-Chat, ja, also ich bin sofort, die sollen sofort Voice-Chat einbauen, habe ich kein
Problem mit, aber dann, dass die Teams nicht bestehen bleiben nach der Runde, das heißt,
du machst das Game anonymer und mit Voice-Chat wieder entanonymisierst du es, du willst
doch, stell dir mal vor, du bist mit jemand hier in der Lobby am Start und ihr versteht
euch gut und ihr labert In-Game-Voice, Team läuft gut und ihr werdet einfach direkt rausgeschmissen
nach der Runde, dann müsst ihr euch adden und könnt zusammen neu suchen und so was,
ja, aber das ist doch doof, warum bleiben die Squats nicht einfach bestehen?
Klar, ich weiß, warum das so ist, weil es irgendwelche Kacknoobs davon abhalten könnte,
um das Spiel länger zu spielen und wenn sie das Spiel nicht länger spielen, kaufen sie
keine Microtransaction-Season-Passes oder sonst was, ja, und sie brauchen es natürlich
für ihr angeblich nicht vorhandenes SBMM, das brauchen sie ja auch, aber ich sage euch,
das ist echte, ich habe es von Anfang an prediktet mit dem Server-Browser, dass es keinen gibt
und es wird nicht lange dauern, dass rauskommt, dass dieses Spiel auch SBMM hat, ich sage
euch, so wie es ist, und da gibt es Leute, die sagen, Max, mit 128 Spielern geht das
gar nicht mit SBMM, natürlich funktioniert das, das mag vielleicht nicht so detailliert
funktionieren, aber du kannst im Prinzip alles mehr oder weniger scalen von klein und funktioniert
ziemlich gut, so ein bisschen größer funktioniert noch halbwegs passabel, musst du ja auch
gar nicht mit 128 Spielern, das muss ja gar nicht so genau gefeintuned sein, es gibt keinen
Server-Browser, nein, gibt es nicht, in Portal gibt es einen Server-Browser, aber das ist
überhaupt kein Ersatz für den Kernspielmodus, der keinen Server-Browser hat, diese All-of-Warfare-Geschichte
hat keinen Server-Browser, nein, und ich habe es prediktet, vor über einem Jahr habe ich
ein Video zugemacht, da haben alle so, nein, Max, das kann überhaupt nicht sein, war Battlefield
00 Server-Browser, nein, nein, da wird es niemals, es wird sein, ich kann euch das aber auch,
ich kann euch das instant sagen, ob es SBMM gibt, nämlich am 19., ich habe jetzt ja relativ
viel gespielt, ich glaube, zum größten Teil auch ganz brauchbar, bestimmt nicht super
krass Elite-Stells, aber ganz brauchbar, wenn ich am 19. nicht alles voller Noobs habe,
dann gibt es SBMM, ganz einfach.
Joa, Bock ist auch nicht tamam.
Joa, gibt es nicht.
Wenn das das ist, was du tun willst, dann geh für es.
Wir müssen es einfach anstecken.
Aber wirklich, die meisten dieser Dinge sollten nur in der Spielzeit sein.
Ich meine, eine Statistik-Page.
Das kann sein, weil es eine artistische Richtung ist.
Das sollte einfach ein Ding sein.
Lieber Dice,
nehmt nicht den Fuß des Acceleratores.
Bitte.
Das hat mit Battlefield V passiert.
Und mit den Weihnachten, die nach Weihnachten kommen,
bin ich ein wenig versorgt.
Das wird langsam.
Eine Menge Zeit und Effort wurde über die letzten drei oder so Jahre in diesem Spiel gespielt.
Und um die meisten von hierher zu kommen,
ist ein riesiges Erlebnis.
Ich kann es schlecht einschätzen, wie krass die Herausforderung ist, Corona Homeoffice für Spieleentwickler.
Aber ich übertrag das mal so ein bisschen auf das bei uns.
Ob ich jetzt den ganzen Tag am Rechner auf der Arbeit sitze oder am ganzen Tag am Rechner daheim.
In der Regel klappt das daheim sogar besser.
Und ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es die Herausforderung so sehr steigert
für die Spieleentwicklung, wenn die Leute von daheim arbeiten.
Ja, nur weil es zwar ab und zu Level 1 gibt. Gut, die können ja reingeworfen werden zum Testen.
Mittlerweile bin ich eher der Meinung, ich würde wundern, wenn es nicht sowas gibt.
Das kann ja sein, dass es nicht so krass wie in Call of Duty ist,
aber mich würde wundern, wenn es sowas nicht gibt.
Was bringt die ganze Anonymisierung von Scoreboard wegmachen und sonstige Geschichten,
wenn man nicht im Zuge dessen eben solche Noob-Schutz-Mechanismen wie SBMM einführt?
Also warum sollte man das eine ohne das andere machen?
Oder warum sollte man das überhaupt einbauen, wenn nicht als Voraussetzung dafür?
Nö, das Game hat keinen Inhalt.
Nein, sowohl Hazard Zone als auch Portal ist kein Ersatz für das Kern Battlefield.
Sie sind doch nicht incredible, die haben das Game mega verkackt.
Das ist so ein typisches Video, der muss es so super freundlich Kleinigkeiten auferhypen,
damit die ganzen Ultra-Fanboys ihm nicht aufs Dach steigen.
Das Spiel kann schon wirklich Bock machen, das will ich auch gar nicht mal bestreiten,
aber ich sehe das Gold unter der Oberfläche nicht bei Battlefield 2042,
wohingegen ich es bei Battlefield 4 gesehen habe, trotz verbacktem Kack am Anfang.
Guckt euch doch nur mal die Maps an, das ist einfach offen zu 90% Gelände,
diese Sachen, diese Hotspots hier mit den Gebäuden, das kann schon wirklich Bock machen,
aber die ganzen anderen Sachen sind in Conquest quasi entweder, also aktuell,
entweder fährst du mit dem Hovercraft rum oder die Helis zerficken dich instant.
So läuft es aktuell in Conquest.
Und im Prinzip hat in Conquest nur die Seite Spaß mit Luftüberlegenheit,
weil es gibt einfach nichts, wo du dich irgendwie, du hast ja mal da Häuschen
und da mal irgendwie eine Lagerhalle, du kannst ja nicht die ganze,
du willst doch nicht die ganze Runde um eine Lagerhalle spielen in Conquest.
Also 2042 von der Grafik nicht so nice aus wie Battlefield 4, naja doch,
es sieht schon gut aus, die Sache ist nur die, dass es detailarm ist, wie ich finde.
Also der grafische Unterbau, also das Frostbite Gerüst ist schon echt gut,
kannst dir nichts sagen, aber es ist halt sehr detailarm.
Also es wirkt halt so, als bräuchten die Maps noch bestimmt ein halbes Jahr
intern bisschen Iterationen und Ausprobieren und Fine-Tuning
und vor allem eben auch ein bisschen mehr Liebe zum Detail.
Ja es hat, ich meine guckt euch mal die Brücke in Kaleidoskop an,
das ist ein leerer Betonblock.
Weiß ich, ob man das hier irgendwo sieht, ob hier irgendwo die Brücke
hoch und runter gefahren wird im Video?
Hier, guckt euch das an, das ist eine fucking Brücke, was ist das?
Das sieht aus wie ein Block aus Unreal 1, das soll eine Brücke sein.
Das hat kein Geländer, das hat keine richtige Straße, das hat nichts.
Das ist, und irgendwie klitscht es hier auch gerade raus, das ist ein Block aus Half-Life 1.
Das ist gerade auch ernsthaft, doch ich sag nichts, es hat anscheinend wirklich ein Geländer.
Das ist doch kein, nee.
Das sieht aus wie eine Xbox 3, wie eine Xbox 1 Brücke, also die Xbox 0 Brücke.
The PC Performance in particular FPS on high settings.
General bug fixes and optimization on PC, I think it's okay on console,
but on PC at least it just has to be a priority right now, it's crazy.
It nearly makes some maps unplayable like Manifest.
Add back in some of those legacy features the online community is crying out for.
Maybe have another look at the real core of the multiplayer experience.
By the way, Panzerplatten nerven mich übrigens auch ziemlich,
weil du nicht mehr predikten kannst, wann Gegner downgehen.
Anything can be tweaked to make it more familiar on the surface level.
Keep the gameplay loop, I think most of the experience is really good fun.
The sandbox nature of everything is really in the spotlight with 2042.
And fans are definitely having fun.
I just think a little more should be done to smooth out those edges
and really nail what the Battlefield experience is supposed to be.
Das Game muss quasi nochmal zur Hälfte komplett überarbeitet werden,
dass da was Gutes rauskommt.
Nicht sagen, dass es little more ist.
Granted, most of it isn't constructive, but behind it all is a point of shock.
Warum schaffen sie es sich so was wie Battlefield 3 aufzustellen, nur moderner?
Weil die glaube ich einfach keine Leute mehr haben, die das passende Gespür dafür haben.
Und das kommt wahrscheinlich noch dazu, weil wir in anderen Zeiten leben.
Wahrscheinlich Management und oberes Management und noch höheres Management
und dann kommt wahrscheinlich Bobby selbst vorbei.
Moment, wir sind ja bei EA, wir sind ja nicht bei Activision.
Oberstonkstyp selbst vorbei und sagt das und das muss aber sein
und die Leute sagen ja Moment, das passt überhaupt nicht in unser Design,
dann sagt er mir doch scheißegal.
Ja, das ist so eine Kombination aus allem.
Zu viel Stonksleute, die mitreden und wahrscheinlich tatsächlich auch zu viele Leute,
die oder zu wenige Leute, die noch wissen, was richtiges Battlefield ausmacht.
Ich meine, hier ist nichts drinne in den Räumen.
Das ist einfach leer.
Hier oben an der Decke siehst du, die können, wenn sie wollen.
Aber was ich meine, hier ist nichts drinne.
Das ist einfach leer.
Hier oben an der Decke siehst du, die können, wenn sie wollen.
Aber was ich meine, hier ist nichts drinne.
Das ist einfach leer.
Hier oben an der Decke siehst du, die können, wenn sie wollen.
Aber was ich meine, hier ist einfach nichts drinne.
Vor allem, warum ist das ein Rechenzentrum mit RGB-Räumen?
Hier ist einfach nichts drinne.
Das soll eine Kunstgalerie sein, ja ok.
Krass moderne Kunst.
Da habe ich jetzt mal eine Pflanze gesehen.
Das sieht so steril aus.
Ich meine, nur mal zur Erinnerung.
Und die Battlefield 3-Maps waren definitiv kein Wunder der Detailverliebtheit.
Das war aber damals auch schlicht und ergreifend, also erstens mal dem Gameplay geschuldet.
Man wollte wahrscheinlich nicht zu viel reinstellen oder sonst wie.
Aber das war gar nicht das Problem.
Das Hauptproblem war wahrscheinlich eher, dass es eben auf der Xbox 360 sonst was wie laufen musste.
Ich meine vergleicht mal Siebertower damit.
Guck mal, der sieht wenigstens in irgendeiner Art und Weise nach Büro aus.
Das ist auch sehr steril, klar.
Aber das ist ein Xbox 360 Game.
Aber das geht als Bürogebäude durch.
Da hast du ein Klo.
Da kannst du Peppupupu machen drauf.
Du hast irgendwo einen Pool.
Also klar, man sieht schon, der Style ist relativ ähnlich tatsächlich.
Aber hier ist halt was da.
Hier hast du diese Sonnenbänke und sowas, was auch immer die da machen.
Da ist halt was da.
Ja hier das Zeug, das sieht nach einem Gebäude aus.
Das macht auch nicht wirklich Sinn.
Das sieht halt nach einem Halbweg.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Hier steht mehr.
Hier ist mehr drauf als in dem ganzen Korridor des gesamten Gebäudes in BF2042.
Und das ist ein Xbox 360 Game.
Den hat einfach die Zeit gefehlt.
Muss ich jetzt einfach mal loswerden.
Da muss noch sehr, sehr viel gemacht werden.
Auch vieles im Kern nochmal überarbeitet werden.
Es ist nicht nur Feintuning und Balancing, was da gemacht werden muss.
Bellevue 3 Grafik ist zeitlos.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ja, schon ziemlich.
Okay.
Leute, ich glaube, ich gehe jetzt auf.
Schon spät.
Bedgetime.
Liegt gerade, ob ich noch irgendjemand hosten soll.
Witzig.
Ein anderer Battlefield-Streamer, den ich ab und zu gucke, spielt wieder Battlefield 3.
Null W.
War ja klar.
Keine Ahnung.
Tauscht jetzt keinen.
Also ich gehe ins Bett, Leute.
Wir sehen uns.
Bis denn.
Macht's gut.
Tschüss.